so it's interesting you're talking about
why people have done bad things in the
name of morality but how do we get
morality than without religion how do we
using science and this is what you've
written a lot about how do we use
science to get some sense of morality so
we don't end up doing the same things
that the religious people are using
right well so well it starts with the
idea the recognition that that moral
values are part of our human nature we
have a sense of right and wrong and
justice and it's built into us and you
can see it in all humans and actually
all primates even other mammals like
elephants and dogs and so on they have a
sense of guilt and and and shame and
things like that and they and they have
a certain amount of empathy sympathy
cooperativeness as well as selfishness
and greediness and so and they have
these suite of moral emotions maybe
scale down from what we have but so it's
there in our nature we evolved it we got
it it's part of the package of just
being human and then for that was just a
survival thing right like just Darwin
like you have to play nice with people
otherwise they're gonna exactly okay so
you start with something like Dawkins
you know Selfish Gene model and you know
what what what does but what would a you
know a self-replicating molecule do to
perpetuate itself into the future it
needs to build a you know a cell to put
itself in and then multiple cells and
then an organism you know survival
machine to carry it forward so our
bodies are you know beholden to the the
genes we are the genes survival machine
and so why shouldn't I just be a selfish
and greedy as I possibly can hoard all
the resources take all your stuff you
know I knock you on the head and take
you know well because you would do the
same calculation as me and I know that
you know that I might be thinking that
and I know that you know that I know
that you might be thinking that and so
therefore maybe it's better if I'm just
nice to you and but I can't just fake
and pretend I'm a nice person because in
time you will pick up the cue subtle
cues that I I'm not genuine
about you I'm I'm just coldly
manipulating your emotions to get
something in time people can see that in
other people so you can't just fake it
you have to actually believe it and
actually feel like I want to be a good
person yeah and and so you have that
tension then think the good moral
motions and the dark side emotions and
they're there for all of this so isn't
that strange though because that does
show sort of you're giving me the
scientific explanation of why to be good
and then at the same time that is sort
of why religion would tell people to be
good - right - to better their community
or to work with people or that kind of
thing so there is some place that you
could use both of those things to come
well I think what religions discovered
this by by trial and error over
thousands of years there are certain
things that we shouldn't do because most
people don't like it you know so you
know killing and you know this kind of
thing even though there's a lot of bad
survival they kind of figured out look
for a community so we need a set of
rules you know maybe we disagree about
the rules but dang we need the rules and
everybody has to obey Him and if not
then there be punishments and if you
think you got away with it because there
was no one around there's an eye in the
sky you know this is in a way the basis
of God yeah beliefs in part there's
multiple reasons for God but that's one
of them there's you know there's a moral
eye in the sky keeping track now if
you're a psychopath and you don't care
well alright it's not gonna work for you
but for the bulk of the population that
would work yeah and so in a way I you
know the conservative Christian belief
and the sinful nature of humans isn't in
a way a Darwinian model as well because
yes we're greedy and we if we think we
can get away with it we might so and
it's sort of like a prisoner's dilemma
or a game theory type model you know tit
for tat and you know okay I'll start off
cooperating if you cooperate I'll
cooperate again but if you defect that
I'm gonna I'm gonna nail you for that
right so that that desired of to nail
you to get justice for the thing you did
that was wrong that's actually a good
strategy you know the Gandhian turned
the other cheek Jesus turn the other
cheek that's not a good games theory
strategy because that just means you'll
be exploited by other people right it
never works out well for that person no
and it doesn't and it won't work for a
whole
society those kinds of societies won't
survive because other groups will clans
or whatever will try it will take them
over so it actually helps to cultivate
reputation of being a badass no you take
my stuff I'm gonna kick your ass yeah
okay all right all right okay but you're
coming to that point using a moral
compass right I mean you're you're
saying I'm doing this sort of for myself
but it that in itself is sort of for the
greater good right well but it's a bite
the greater good it turns out to be a
byproduct but I think there's
evolutionary arguments you can make that
that that actually really is good for
the group not a group selection argument
just that the more of us individuals
that are cooperating within our group
our group will be better off for that
yeah the group is not the target of
selection still the individuals right
but societies are better off tonight so
what I argue in the moral arc is that
over the centuries tweaking social
political and economic systems this way
in this way we've been kind of hovering
around this idea that there is a better
way to live for more in a utilitarian
type right more of us will be better off
and live longer and prosperous and
healthy lives if we do this rather than
that you know a democracy versus a
dictatorship a relatively free markets
of trading and allowing people you know
to do with their thing versus a
command-and-control economy like in
North Korea or having a set of rules and
a rule of law and a police force is good
good good fences make good neighbors
right so we've been doing this these
experiments so that's what I mean it's
kind of like a science it's like okay
let's run the experiment and see how it
goes and then we'll tweak the variables
in four years called an election we'll
try it again right and and there's no
they're there to get there there's no
you taupe we r just trying to make a
little bit of progress so we'll increase
taxes there and lower them there or
we'll well change the gun control laws
here but not there and we'll see let's
just see what happens right so you're
saying when politicians promise they can
fix everything they're not actually
telling I know yeah what do you what do
you make of people that would believe
everything that you've said that live
their lives in a secular way using
science and reason and
their own personal morality to guide
their lives but at the same time do take
that leap of faith and still believe in
some crazy stuff still believe that
maybe there's someone upstairs watching
them cuz I think I think that's probably
where most people fall that they do live
their lives based in secular ideas but
at the same time if you really sat them
down and said well do you but you know
because people want to believe at the
end that they're gonna go and you know
play tennis with God well there be
competition in heaven this is what I
want to know because if it's too boring
yeah there's nothing to be worried
wouldn't be worth it you know yeah but
what do you make of that type of person
it's a super good point because in
reality most say conservative Christians
today are more liberal socially than
liberals were in the 50s say but they
don't even know it they're just like
well I I'm doing this because it says so
in the Bible and I'm a Christian and
Jesus you know was like that he said you
know Jesus should love all the gays and
and blacks and so I was like where does
he say that and are you getting this
right I know where they're getting
they're getting it from culture that
it's been shifting for grades from the
bottom up just from everybody changing
the way they talk and think about that
shows are presented as scripts are
written novels books and so forth and
all of us have changed our expanded our
moral sphere to be more encompassing and
so that the standouts like the the
Donald Sterling's of the world who you
know insults African Americans is the
owner of the Clippers this you know his
life is just you know ruined for this
idiotic statements but most old guys
back in the 50s used to think like him
my my dad was kind of like that and it's
like dad you know is that one of the
scary things about society's changing
too quickly I mean I know I follow you
on Twitter and you do push against some
of this regressive left stuff and some
of the social justice warrior stuff
because in a way they're gonna come for
us
two things will keep changing and then
some of the things that you're saying
right now that don't sound controversial
at all to me depending on the way we
evolve and the depending on the way
ideas you know the way that they move
throughout time someone 20 years from
now could look at this and say
you see Shermer was a real bigot for
some reason we can't even think of right
yeah right right yeah of course I we you
know we worry about that or wonder about
that you know that we look back on say
the debates about interracial marriage
it's like what were they thinking right
and and just you know last year looking
back and you know gay marriage what were
they thinking yeah we know what they're
thinking is we so recent and so but now
what are we thinking now that in 20
years people go what what yeah I I think
about that all the time I'm tweeting out
all this stuff all the time and is 20
years from now is someone gonna go man
that guy was a complete lunatic you say
now that would be fun we don't know
because we're buried in the culture it's
just hard to say I will say you know
just projecting forward maybe the rights
of the unborn and here I don't mean
fetuses I mean future generations to
inhabit at Earth that's inevitable that
is there's resources available and so on
so they had you know the environmental
movement I think is is as part of that
you know that would be one area you know
artificial intelligence is maybe another
one you know what is data a person you
know you know do they have personhood
you know those kinds of things I think
we can think about although those are
not particularly controversial the
social justice warriors so-called
regressive left it's an interesting term
that's really caught on yeah that was
maajid imagine you know it's you know so
I thought I think it's very effective
that's an example of how far first of
all how far we've come
how much moral progress we've made that
if the biggest thing on your plate as a
college student is to protest Halloween
right really that's it that's yeah I
mean that means things are pretty dang
good so is that the part that we need to
focus on more then because I do think
that you know we all get in this big
worked-up frenzy over this stuff and
they sent out this letter and you know
they didn't want them to wear offensive
Halloween costumes or something so to
that if you just look at it in that
narrow of you it's like oh [ __ ]
free speech is really being attacked but
if you look at it and I think this is
what you're saying if you look at it
from the broader spectrum it's like look
what's left now we're just fighting over
Halloween right so in that sense things
really have progressed really well
exactly right you compare to say what
students were protesting in the sixties
and seventies and yeah and it's all
right again that's it's
but also the these moral pendulums tend
to swing back and forth to one extreme
to the other and I think it has gone too
far now I mean you know it seems like
free speech as a moral principle is
being trumped by other moral values that
some people hold that the right to not
hear something uncomfortable or
offensive versus yeah like that I was
arguing this back in the 90s with the
Holocaust deniers when I wrote my book
on that investigated them when they were
kind of big and Canada had anti
Holocaust denial laws it was
incorporated under their hate speech
laws I remember first reading about
that's going hate speech what why is
that hates me I mean if you're Jewish I
could see but but who's actually being
harmed by this these guys you could just
just shine a light on him he just yeah
and they'll go nowhere because they
don't have anything mm-hmm
why suppress him and lock him up and
then I remember when David Irving got
arrested in Austria yeah
first you know he didn't even say
anything he was just going to give a
lecture and hitch
Hitchens defended him publicly and I
thought that's good you know there in
this case free speech Trump's you know
that so-called hate speech because the
problem is who determines what's hate
hateful sure and doesn't that hitch
defending him you debating these people
and and allowing for these terrible
ideas right we all know the Holocaust
happened this is a terrible idea to deny
it but doesn't that show you that that
the secularists are pretty consistently
on the right side of things that we are
the ones that are defending ideas yes
even when they are scary to us and
things that we don't like most of you
people most of us right but people don't
you know if you do something that's
against the religion generally religious
people aren't going to defend you
right we're secularists will they'll
stand up for the idea right some
religious to defend free speech and and
they're willing to allow their oh wow
their religion to be criticized but for
the most part most of us you know sort
of circle the wagons and protect our
group or whatever and so it takes an
extra effort it's sort of that type to
cog Jews wait a minute free speech is
really important so you have to sort of
run through the arguments that John
Stuart Mill made in his
on Liberty that okay what if they're
right okay they can't be right yeah but
what if they're right just like a little
bit you know then you learn something
and and second second you can learn
something from just the debate you know
just the just how how confident are you
in your arguments can you explain
evolution by natural selection in five
minutes in a debate because that's what
you got to do right opening statement
rebuttal rebuttal rebuttal Q&A boom boom
boom
can you do it and and when you actually
have to do it like this in the case of
debating the creationist boy I really
sharpened my skills about how do I know
yeah evolution happen what are the like
for best arguments we have and it's
actually kind of a good exercise in that
sense but mostly it's just let this guy
talk mm-hmm and the whole room can see
how idiotic these arguments are just go
for it dude right isn't that a little
bit like when who's that creationist
that did the ham yeah when Ken Ham
debated Bill Nye right and it was like
this was actually ridiculous and all he
had to do was just let him hang himself
yep but we're so afraid of doing that
are like we're so afraid of just letting
someone go and and it's counter to it if
it doesn't feel like yeah we should do
we should circle the wagons and smack
them down but no it's actually better if
you don't if you just provide better
arguments and let the world see you know
how bad those arguments are and yes
maybe he'll convince a few people but in
the long run truth will win out you know
the the bright light of Reason will
shine right I'm pretty sure he was just
trying to sell tickets to the amusement
park or whatever intention and you know
some fundraising for his arc park which
I see is going forward today yeah boy I
don't know bill I know Bilbo is a good
friend and you know he had some doubts
about whether he should do it or not I
think in the long run it was a good
thing to do
yeah good job because there's a fear of
debating these people because then you
could end up debating every crackpot
ever right because there's always and we
see this is something I see you know
every now and again I'll see you argue
with someone on Twitter or some of the
other people that I'm arguing with
somebody and it's like man how much
energy and I'll do it sometimes - how
much energy should we put in to debating
people either that have you know just
ideas that are terrible or aren't
dating from an honest place or that you
know we're gonna twist your words after
and there's a certain opportunity cost
with that there is and and so one of the
criteria I use is to what extent do
people care about this subject is an
influencing thing is it being disgusted
that in the political debates that
currently or is it in the newspapers so
like in the Holocaust deniers back in
the 90s it was kind of a big thing they
were on Donahue I was yeah and Montel
Williams and they were articles written
about them in Time and Newsweek in New
York Times and the Schindler's List came
out and there was big debates they were
challenging and there was articles about
as I thought you know what it's time for
us to engage that what are they claiming
what what exactly so they actually gave
me this list 39 arguments that Holocaust
historians cannot answer I said all
right give me the list right so I
actually went down and just worked my
way through the list and a lot of them
were hard to find actually and when in a
lot of his Holocaust historians that I
consulted they did not know the answers
to these things and now we know because
you know I and others went out and
tracked these things down yeah and you
know Richard Evans did this in the in
Irving's trial David Irving sued Deborah
Lipstadt for calling him a denier mm-hmm
now here's an interesting sociological
thing because I've always called David
Irving a Holocaust denier but he likes
me because we've gone out for beer and
dinner before really and I engage him
and I talk to him David so what's going
on with you Bernie working on now and so
we had this thing so he doesn't meet
likes me he doesn't like Lipstadt
because she she's nasty to him or didn't
talk to him where was it so one of the
things I like to do is as an
investigator I shouldn't call an
experiential journalist because if Sean
Penn could do it maybe I could do you
sort of get out there and you talk to
people and really they do open up if
you're nice and respectful to them
friendly you know what so just tell me
about this what is it you think is going
on because I don't really understand the
arguments they'll kind of open up and
then if you give them a few beers
they'll start talking about you know all
the Jews you know the Jews are doing
that oh really okay
tell me more right so is that how you
ended up sort of beating him in in the
public space that you got to know the
guy you were able to sort of unravel
some of the arguments and I would guess
that it's one of those things
where you can just get when you pull out
one little pin the rest of it starts to
flow exactly right you know I don't say
beat but you know just you sort of lay
it out there here's what he said here's
what he did here's his arguments and so
on and I just let the arguments speak
for themselves and I think they do yeah
and so those guys are largely gone now
and the creationists you know they're
still hanging on the the poll numbers
are starting to shift and the whole
young Earth Creationism is largely being
marginalized
you know the Ben Carson's of the world
you know seventh-day adventists so
they're young earth creationist this is
where all this silliness about the
pyramids come from it's because he's a
seventh-day adventists and it follows
from these other beliefs that he holds
about Genesis and all that but but you
can see he's not going anywhere and he's
just one and more popular is either
pretty mainstream or really not very
religious centrist like Trump you know I
think I think the power of the moral
majority has passed I don't think to get
elected you have to be an uber religious
person anymore yeah you know so Trump
was just at Liberty University and this
is a guy who by any estimation that I've
ever seen has no real religious
religious saw City to him has not even
worried you know but he was up there and
he there was definitely an extra s in
there but he's in there he's at Liberty
University and he's quoting scripture
wrongly it mucked up a couple things but
I was thinking this is really what's
wrong with our political system really
in the most perfect way because here's a
guy who for whatever all the reasons
that people like him is because he's
saying things very clearly whether you
know I mean whether it's true or not
he's just saying and here even he who
says I'm beholden to no one has to
pander still yes to the religious right
so we're not fully out of it yet yeah
definitely I have it know for sure but
yeah you have to have a little bit of it
but it's not that's not what's gonna win
the election I think it's gonna be the
centrist votes yeah at this time which
is more secular just more real-world
problems you know that kind of thing
anyway so but still there it's an intern
oh they're interesting you know that it
seems to be the Republicans the right
are the ones identifying you know the
problem of terrorism what's behind it
you know certain religious beliefs that
are behind it mm-hmm now it's true I
know some of the Isis fighters or young
men out for money and sex and adventure
and whatever but but underneath it is
you know that sort of apocalyptic in
otherworldly utopian society this you
know this kind of really quasi religious
beliefs that are driving them and it's
the left that doesn't seem to want to
acknowledge that they're so afraid this
again political correctness run amok
yeah so afraid to use the word our own
president won't use the word yeah and
he's a guy I admire he's obviously very
bright and thinks that he's a type two
thinker all the way right maybe he'd be
better if he sometimes used tonight
washer at least in this instance because
then he would at least say the word but
yeah this is coming out of the left so I
can I'm a liberal what do I do about
this this has been the theme throughout
the four or five months that we've been
doing this show I understand I've
watched it and I think you're doing
exactly what you could get you have to
what we have to do is push back and you
just push that pendulum back and and if
enough of us do that then it will get
knocked back and people will stop saying
those they'll start identifying things
correctly I think yeah why do you think
the left is so hung up on this one issue
so that if anytime you know I was just
watching some another program where
after the Cologne sex attacks right a
thousand men and there were rapes and
all this terrible stuff that immediately
the argument became well you know
Christians do bad stuff too and you know
the west's done this and we've bombed
this or that this sort of knee-jerk
reaction to make everything this moral
equivalence and sort of make everything
about us whether when it had it been a
thousand Christians that had done this
they never would have flipped it the
other way so what what do I mean we just
keep talking about it well okay well a
couple things first of all why do they
do that well because as Steven Pinker
points out in the blank slate the blank
slate model that you know that culture
determines everything and otherwise
people are equal that's more of a left
wing than right wing view of human
nature conservative Christians have more
of a realistic equals a realistic model
of human nature that is it's both
genetics and culture and and and and
second that again this all inclusiveness
we don't want to offend other people
because look what
we were doing two blacks in the 50s and
60s and Jews in the 30s and 40s and that
was really bad okay so that's sort of
taking a principle and then running with
it right no one's denying that yeah
that's a fact yes that's right
yeah and so therefore it would be wrong
to stereotype all Muslims and butBut it
gets to the point where even if you say
but you preface every sentence with of
course most Muslims are good and nice
and moral people that would never do
this but then you can't even get past
that but what but what yeah now my wife
is from Cologne Germany she's German and
she just moved here last year married me
and we live here now but her we were
gonna go to Cologne next month for
Carnival and now we're not going because
she's worried about really and her
mother was just attacked about a week
ago so this is a week after two weeks
after the New Year's thing and there's a
lot of this going on that's not being
reported because they're afraid to use
the word to say because her mom was
attacked by an Arab looking Syrian man
who said mumbles something about you
know Western women and grabbed her
breasts and knees and really offensive
bottle of booze you know it's a lot of
these young men that are drunk and
they're sort of using this as an excuse
to what extent they're really religious
who knows sure it's a confluence of
bazillion things but that's why we have
to talk about exactly yeah so is that
we're where is that going right yeah so
where's going Angela Merkel who I've
admired very much I think maybe she just
went too far you that we have to do some
screaming but the moment you say
screening then you you are you talking
about targeting certain people and isn't
that stereotyping and doesn't that lead
to genocide okay so you end up down that
road yeah just just take a little status
just a little just a tiny bit good to
find out you know what's going on here
before that's why Trump made that
comment and he's felled a bigoted and
racist but wait he's just saying maybe
we should just figure out what's going
on here first right it gets twisted into
something and I'm not defending what he
says at all and that's that's also why
language is so important to this because
we've gotten so afraid of saying
anything the wrong way or writing
anything the wrong way that you'll
immediately be labeled a bigot a racist
right and the rest of it when all you're
saying is we should have some decent
screening to figure out who's here and
here you also given me a first-hand
example
I mean your wife's mother was attacked
yes this isn't this isn't made-up stuff
no and this you know it's cold she's you
know she's a 65 year old woman all
bundled up with umbrella and hat and
jacket everything and so it's not like
they're out groping young women in bars
wearing miniskirts right it's just just
grab anything that's female and you know
so who knows what the motivations are
you know some of it again is just young
men on you know just on a rampage but
you know but again I think it's not just
random who's doing it and everybody's
afraid to say what it is and so Merkel
who I think has been a great leader I
think she's just gone too far yeah what
do you make of the the situation I
wasn't planning on going here but I'm
glad we're taking this road that Germany
a lot of people are saying and I've had
a lot of people email me about this that
they're saying that the reason that they
opened the borders the way they did was
because there's this incredible guilt
because of the Holocaust there's a note
so they don't want to see people you
know if they if they can help they want
to help but now it's gotten out of
control and now what this is gonna do is
is help the far-right you're seeing
hints of this here with with Trump and
xenophobia and we're seeing this all
over Europe now so again it's when the
left doesn't deal with things honestly
that we allow the right is exactly right
I mean if the left wants to defend their
position they should do the opposite
what they're doing because it's the
right that are gonna be in so my wife
tells me that the the sentiments in
Germany about this and before this
attitudes toward Israel and the Middle
Eastern conflicts is that we just have
to bite our tongue because what we did
was so bad that we just have to always
support Israel and even though there's
there's numbers of people and branches
in the society that do not support
Israel they can't say anything right and
and even though there are debates about
you know Palestinians and who's doing
what and who's the real terrorist and
you know no one has perfectly clean
hands in those in that conflict but in
Germany you can't you can't say this
because of the guilt there's a lot of
guilt yeah and they've had you know they
paid reparations to Israel for a long
time and
you know so Merkel's try to navigate
around is very difficult to do and so in
part there's that but also they're the
strongest nation of the you and she was
trying to set a precedence and I see I
see why she was trying to do that but I
just think it's probably gone too far
and now there's a lot my wife tells me
there's a lot of these strong right you
know Nazi type groups that are now
bubbling up saying see I told you I told
you yeah well actually next week
I have Tommy Robinson on who's the
former head of the EDL who imagined was
he mentioned earlier at one point helped
get him out of the EDL because he felt
it was too far right and there were some
neo-nazi elements and he had emailed me
about coming on the show and I had a
real sort of debate with him myself
whether here's someone who I know a lot
of people think he's just a racist and
then I get a lot of people that say you
know he's he's talking about things that
people don't want to talk about and I
thought well if I talked to him are
people gonna think I'm a racist and then
that was why I felt like I had to do the
interview and I have to because I can't
be afraid of just the conversation and
where that's gonna place me but that's
that's where they've got us right now
right right yeah well but but they're
not they don't have a theory yeah we are
talking about it and we'll do that and
we will push back and that's a good
thing and you know so in in in Germany
in Europe you know they've made a major
transition from 500 years of very tribal
and balkanized constant in conflict
history to you know a completely
different kind of society and so when
these tensions have been bubbling up you
know the temptation is to go back and
but then put no no we don't want to do
that because look what happened this led
to all these conflicts and genocides and
so on but part of the problem is
recognizing that there really are bad
people in the world they really do mean
harm they they really do behead people
and they do bad things for whatever
reason they're not all psychopaths a lot
of them are just morally motivated as I
mentioned 90% of homicides are
moralistic in nature but this is true
for genocides and and ethnic cleansing
zand pogroms they're morally motivated
they have they have raw
ideas and good ideas that dangerous ever
have just stated without religion
because almost all if you think you know
Holocaust pogroms what's happening right
now in Europe all of these things
there's a religious underpinning to all
of them so could this type of mass stuff
ever happened without religion well I
did in the seventies and a 60 70s 80s
with Marxist regimes and terrorists I
mean there was a lot of terrorism in the
70s I mean way more than now CNN just
ran that they had a series the seventies
the eighties yeah and the one in the
seventies one of the episodes was just
an hour long of all the terrorist
attacks I'd forgot you know lived
through it but I forgot how many of
their works yeah and you know to the
point where Monty Python Perry parody
did in the life of Brian
yeah the people's G Dale front the front
of people that's how many they were back
then there was a you know that the rates
of murders were much higher in bombings
and in the United States those are but
those were moralistically driven you
know but but it's it's a kind of because
Marxism is sort of a quasi-religious so
what's behind when we say religion it's
this idea of a utopian society there's a
place we can get to either heaven above
or heavens on earth we can get there if
it weren't for those people that are
stopping us the capitalists the
imperialists the or you know the Jews or
the Christians or the you know whoever
it is you know so it's engaging the
moral module in the brain whatever that
is to be worked up about a cause right
so that's I love that concept that it's
you're always fighting the other whoever
the other is and it can be through the
religious prism or the secular prism and
it's sort of up to us to figure out
which one we're gonna exactly know I'm
worried about the EU and in Germany
because you know they've been moving in
the right direction of very porous
borders you can travel across all the
countries there's no border checks and
it's just like driving across the United
States now it's great and and they've
been much more economically prosperous
because of that and politically more
freedom and more democracies all those
things
are good but now there's this I'm
fearful there'll be a backlash close
those borders bulk and I see it's
happening right now right and and and
then if they abandon the currency the
euro is a currency that's gonna be bad
economically